This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. At various points in our lives, all of us turn to coaches and trainers. If you're a student athlete, you might need a coach to improve your tennis stroke or soccer footwork. If you need to take up a musical instrument in your 30s, you'll need the help of a piano teacher or guitar instructor. If you decide you want to learn a new language in your 50s, you sign up for classes with an expert in that language. But there are lots of domains in our lives where many of us never dream of recruiting the help of a coach.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在我们人生的不同阶段，我们都会向教练和导师求助。如果你是一名学生运动员，你可能需要一位教练来改进你的网球挥拍或足球步法。如果你在30多岁时想学习一种乐器，你需要钢琴老师或吉他教练的帮助。如果你决定在50多岁时学习一门新语言，你会报名参加由该语言专家开设的课程。但在我们生活的许多领域，许多人从未想过要寻求教练的帮助。
That's because we feel we are masters in those domains already. We don't need a coach to help us breathe or walk or talk. Or do we? Just because we've done something a long time doesn't mean we are doing it right. Just because we feel we are skilled at something doesn't mean we don't have plenty of room for improvement. Today on the show we focus on a skill that seems so commonplace that many of us fail to see how difficult it is to do well.
那是因为我们觉得自己在这些领域已经是大师了。我们不需要教练来教我们如何呼吸、走路或说话。真的是这样吗？仅仅因为我们做某件事已经很久了，并不意味着我们做得对。仅仅因为我们觉得自己在某方面很在行，并不意味着我们没有很大的提升空间。今天在节目中，我们将重点讨论一项看似如此普遍，以至于我们许多人都没意识到它有多难做好的技能。
We're going to look at how we engage in conversation and the things we can do to get better at it. Learning to talk. This week on Hidden Brain. When discussing the children in our lives, we say they learn to talk at age one or two. For the late bloomers, maybe it's three or four. We make it sound as if learning to talk is something we master early, and then practice without a problem as adults. But it turns out that most of us have a lot to learn
我们将探讨我们是如何进行对话的，以及我们可以做些什么来提高对话能力。学习说话。本周的《Hidden Brain》。在谈论我们的孩子时，我们说他们在一两岁时学会说话。对于晚熟的孩子，可能是三四岁。我们说得好像学习说话是我们很早就掌握的技能，然后作为成年人可以毫无问题地实践。但事实证明，我们大多数人还有很多东西要学，
when it comes to having conversations that are dynamic, engaging, and meaningful. Allison Woodbrooks is a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School. For many years now, she has studied the science of conversation. Allison Woodbrooks, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Alison, when you were younger, you went on a blind date that was memorable for all the
尤其是在进行动态、引人入胜且有意义的对话方面。艾莉森·伍德布鲁克斯是哈佛商学院的行为科学家。多年来，她一直致力于研究对话科学。艾莉森·伍德布鲁克斯，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。非常感谢邀请我。艾莉森，当你年轻的时候，你曾有过一次令人难忘的相亲，但原因却
wrong reasons. Can you paint me a picture of what your life was like at the time and who this mystery man was? Yes, I was living in New York City and I was set up on a blind date by a friend. It might have been the only blind date that I've been on in my life. And it was with a man who had a job, a good job, great job in finance. He had gone to a good college.
完全不对。你能描绘一下你当时的生活是什么样的，以及这个神秘男人是谁吗？是的，我当时住在纽约市，一位朋友给我安排了一次相亲。这可能是我一生中唯一的一次相亲。对方是一个有工作的人，一份好工作，一份很棒的金融工作。他毕业于一所不错的大学。
He'd played football in college. And I had seen photos of, my friend had shown me photos of this guy and he was so handsome. So I was excited. I went and I met him downtown for dinner at this sort of busy, bustling, loud restaurant slash bar. And I settle into the table and off we go. So he in some ways is the real life version of that popular meme that's been going around
他在大学里踢过足球。我见过照片，朋友给我看过这个人的照片，他非常帅。所以我很兴奋。我去了市中心，在一家那种繁忙、喧闹、嘈杂的餐厅兼酒吧和他见面。我坐到桌边，我们就开始了。所以他在某些方面是那个广为流传的流行梗的现实版，
which says, I'm looking for a man in finance, trust fund, six-five, blue eyes. Exactly. I don't know about the trust fund, but truly everything else, this was this sort of Adonis of a man that so many women, I think, are hoping to meet, yes. All right. So that's very optimistic and hopeful. So what happens when the dinner gets underway? So I settle into this table at this buzzy restaurant in New York City, downtown. And I mean, across from me at this table is this beautiful man.
那个梗说：“我在找一个在金融界工作、有信托基金、身高6英尺5英寸、蓝眼睛的男人。”没错。我不知道他有没有信托基金，但确实其他一切都符合，他就是那种很多女性都希望能遇到的阿多尼斯般的男人，是的。好的。那真是非常乐观和充满希望。那么晚餐开始后发生了什么？我坐在纽约市中心那家热闹的餐厅里。我的意思是，坐在我对面的是这个漂亮的男人。
And I'm so excited. And we just launch into a conversation. Now the whole point of a first date is to get to know each other. So I am pelting him with questions. Where is he from? What's his family like? What was his college like? What was it like to play football
我太兴奋了。我们直接开始了对话。第一次约会的全部意义在于互相了解。所以我一直在向他抛出问题。他是哪里人？他的家庭怎么样？他的大学生活是什么样的？在那里踢足球是什么感觉，
there, tell me more about your football career, what's your job like now, where do you live, do you have lots of friends in the city? So I'm asking him lots of questions and I realize that 10 minutes have gone by and he has not asked me a single thing about myself. 10 minutes. And I realized at this point that this has been a complete sort of absence of question asking in my direction. And at that point, you sort of have this out of body experience and I'm floating over the table,
多跟我讲讲你的足球生涯，你现在的工作怎么样，你住在哪里，你在城里有很多朋友吗？所以我问了他很多问题，然后我意识到10分钟过去了，他甚至没有问我关于我自己的任何事情。10分钟。我意识到在这一点上，我这边完全没有被问到任何问题。在那一刻，你会有种灵魂出窍的感觉，我漂浮在桌子上方，
looking down at this conversation game that's now afoot. And you start to play this little game where you're like, how many questions can I ask this person before they ask a single question back to me? Like how far can I push this? And I think he doesn't really realize that I'm now playing this game. And he certainly doesn't realize how badly he's losing the game. And another 10 minutes go by. 20 minutes, he has asked me nothing about myself.
俯视着这场正在进行中的对话游戏。你开始玩这个小游戏，心想：在他问我一个问题之前，我能问他多少个问题？我可以把这个推到什么程度？我想他并没有意识到我正在玩这个游戏。他当然也没有意识到他输得有多惨。又过了10分钟。20分钟了，他什么都没问我。
He has no idea that I'm like devastated and really feeling sort of hurt, but he doesn't seem reciprocally interested in me. reciprocally interested in me. I'm assuming at this point you're asking yourself how you can extricate yourself from the date. Absolutely. How quickly can I get out of here? So I excuse myself to the restroom and I sort of collect myself, you know, I'm looking in
他根本不知道我当时有多崩溃，感觉很受伤，但他似乎对我没有回馈性的兴趣。对我没有回馈性的兴趣。我假设此时你正在问自己如何从这次约会中脱身。绝对是。我能多快离开这里？所以我借口去洗手间，整理了一下自己，你知道，我看着
the mirror, maybe touch up my lipstick and I'm thinking, what do I do now? And this really decisive feeling washes over me. I just got to go. I got to get out of here. There's just no way that I have a future with someone who can go 20 minutes without asking me a question, right? I need someone who's interested in me and my perspective and my feelings and my life. And so I make my way back to the table having made this decision. I say thank you so much for meeting me for dinner. I have
镜子，也许补了补口红，我在想，我现在该怎么办？一种非常果断的感觉涌上心头。我必须走。我必须离开这里。和一个20分钟都不问我一个问题的人在一起，我绝对没有未来，对吧？我需要一个对我、我的观点、我的感受和我的生活感兴趣的人。所以我做出了这个决定，回到了桌边。我说非常感谢你和我共进晚餐。我
to go and I collect my things and I leave. Did you ever hear from him again? I did. He texted me later that night and he said, you're beautiful. I had a great time. I want to see you again. Which by the way, still, there is no question. I mean, it's like fine, lovely, but he's still, there's no question of, are you okay?
得走了，我收拾好东西就离开了。你后来还有他的消息吗？有的。那天晚上晚些时候他给我发了短信，他说：“你很漂亮。我玩得很开心。我想再见到你。”顺便说一句，依然没有问题。我的意思是，这很好，很可爱，但他仍然没有问：“你还好吗？
How are you doing? Did you get home safely? Is everything all right? No question. I mean, it was really quite wild. And, you know, I'm a bit of a people pleaser. I don't usually, I'm not usually overly direct with people, but this moment felt like he really could benefit from some feedback.
你怎么样？你安全到家了吗？一切都好吗？”没有问题。我的意思是，这真的很疯狂。而且，你知道，我有点讨好型人格。我通常不会对人过于直接，但那一刻我觉得他确实可以从一些反馈中受益。
I mean, his future girlfriend who's looking for a man with blue eyes and a job in finance and six-five is going to find this guy and I want him to be able to make that person happy. And so I text him back and I just say, I just want you to know I left because you didn't ask me anything about myself. And it really made me feel like you weren't interested in me. I'm really grateful that you met up with me and I wish you the best. There was another instance in your life, Alison, that illustrated in some ways the nature of conversational pitfalls. You went out for dinner with a good friend of yours.
我的意思是，他未来的女朋友，那个正在寻找蓝眼睛、金融工作、身高6英尺5英寸的男人的女孩，会找到这个家伙，我希望他能让那个人幸福。所以我回了他短信，我说：“我只想让你知道我离开了，因为你没有问我关于我自己的任何事情。这真的让我觉得你对我没兴趣。我很感激你和我见面，祝你一切顺利。”艾莉森，你生活中还有另一个例子，在某种程度上说明了对话陷阱的本质。你和一位好朋友出去吃晚饭。
There was something you had been working up the nerve to tell her. Who was this friend and what had you wanted to tell her? Oh, yes. This was a dear friend of mine. We had been friends for a very long time, coming up on ten years. And she was dating a guy who was great, but I just wasn't sure they were a good fit for each other. And I knew that they were starting to think about and getting engaged and maybe married. And probably for over a year, I had just been sort of feeling kind of worried about her.
有些话你一直鼓起勇气想告诉她。这位朋友是谁，你想告诉她什么？哦，是的。这是我的一位挚友。我们认识很久了，快十年了。她当时在和一个很棒的男人约会，但我只是不确定他们是否合适。我知道他们开始考虑订婚甚至结婚了。可能有一年多的时间，我一直对她感到有点担心。
Like, is this the right person for you? She was so spectacular. And I just felt like maybe he wasn't right for her. And so I'd been grappling with this idea, should I raise this with her? Should we talk about it? Is our friendship strong enough that we could handle a topic like this? Is it my place to even raise a topic like this,
比如，他是对的人吗？她太出色了。我只是觉得也许他不适合她。所以我一直在纠结这个问题，我应该向她提出来吗？我们应该谈谈吗？我们的友谊是否足够牢固，可以处理这样的话题？甚至提出这样的话题是我的事吗，
even with someone that I'm so close to? So did you raise it at the dinner? Yeah. So we were at this sort of trendy restaurant downtown and there was music thumping and we were eating delicious foods and having cocktails and I worked up the, finally mustered the courage to tell her what had been on my mind. And I could tell that she was both intrigued and interested in what I was telling her and she engaged with me on it so nicely. But, you know, as so many hard conversations,
即使是对我如此亲近的人？所以你在晚餐时提到了吗？是的。我们在市中心一家很时髦的餐厅，音乐声很大，我们吃着美味的食物，喝着鸡尾酒，我终于鼓起勇气告诉她我心里的想法。我能看出她对我所说的话既好奇又感兴趣，她也很好地回应了我。但是，你知道，就像许多艰难的对话一样，
hard topics become more difficult over time, I've realized that she'd heard me, she was maybe getting a little bit emotional, and so I didn't wanna push it. And I switched topics and we moved on. So after this dinner, I felt so proud that I had worked up the courage to be direct and honest with my friend. I'm proud of her for being so receptive to my perspective. And it just, I felt like the conversation had gone really well. So fast
艰难的话题随着时间的推移变得更加困难，我意识到她听到了我的话，她可能变得有点情绪化，所以我不想再逼她了。我转换了话题，我们继续聊别的。晚餐后，我为自己鼓起勇气对朋友坦诚直率感到自豪。我为她能如此接受我的观点感到骄傲。我觉得对话进行得非常好。快进
forward two days and a text message pops up on my phone from my friend. And immediately I'm so curious. I'm thinking, oh my gosh, did I change her mind? Had she been thinking about this? Is she ready to open up about maybe she's been wondering about this guy too and maybe they, she kind of knows they're not a good fit for each other. And she's going to say, thank you so much for empowering me to really say this out loud. I was excited to see how she was gonna react and I opened my phone, I opened the text message and what do I see? I see
两天，我的手机上弹出了一条来自我朋友的短信。我立刻感到非常好奇。我在想，天哪，我改变她的主意了吗？她一直在思考这个问题吗？她准备好敞开心扉谈论也许她也一直在怀疑这个男人，也许她也知道他们不合适吗？她会说：“非常感谢你赋予我力量，让我真正把这些话说出来。”我很兴奋地想看看她会有什么反应，我打开手机，打开短信，我看到了什么？我看到
a photo. It's very clearly her hand. It's the same bright red nail polish she'd been wearing at our dinner just two nights before, and a beautiful diamond ring on her ring finger her boyfriend had proposed and she had said yes. Wow, so when you had that conversation with her at dinner, she wasn't being reticent because she was thinking deeply about what you were saying. She was probably saying, I don't know how to tell Alison that in fact my boyfriend has proposed or is about to propose. That's right. And that she had already helped him pick out the ring. Oh, wow. is about to propose. That's right. And that she had already helped him pick out the ring. I think she was grappling with a lot of feelings in that moment. She didn't want to embarrass me, she didn't want to hurt me. Maybe I made her feel embarrassed that she was ready to go forward with
一张照片。很明显是她的手。那是她两天前在我们晚餐时涂的同样的亮红色指甲油，无名指上戴着一枚漂亮的钻戒，她男朋友求婚了，她答应了。哇，所以当你在晚餐时和她谈话时，她并不是因为在深思你说的话而沉默。她可能在想，我不知道该怎么告诉艾莉森，事实上我男朋友已经求婚了，或者正要求婚。没错。而且她已经帮他选好了戒指。哦，哇。正要求婚。没错。而且她已经帮他选好了戒指。我想她在那一刻正纠结于很多感受。她不想让我尴尬，她不想伤害我。也许我让她觉得她准备好迈出人生中这一大步感到尴尬。或者也许，这是，也许她根本没听进去，你知道，我只是随口提了一下，我不想把它变成一件戏剧性的事情。我们很快就换了话题。所以也许她甚至没能处理我所说的话。我不知道，因为我们再也没有谈过这件事。是的，我的意思是，艾莉森，在男朋友向她求婚前几分钟，你告诉她要和他分手，你一定感觉糟透了。我感觉糟透了。我觉得自己是个糟糕的朋友，是个糟糕的人，
this huge step in her life. Or maybe, and this is, maybe she didn't really hear me, you know, I kind of mentioned it quickly and I didn't go, I didn't want to make it a dramatic thing. And we moved on quickly. So maybe she wasn't even really able to process what I was saying. I don't know, because we, we never talked about it again. Yeah, I mean you must have felt terrible, Allison, at telling her to break up with her boyfriend, you know, moments before he proposed her marriage to her. I felt horrible. I felt like such a terrible friend and such a terrible person and
是个糟糕的人，好像我没有尽到好朋友的责任，去为她感到兴奋和支持，去陪伴她。我非常担心我的反馈玷污了他在单膝下跪说“你愿意嫁给我吗”时的那一刻。我的意思是，我担心我突然出现在她的脑海里。如果哪怕有一秒钟她在想，也许我不应该这样做，因为我的朋友不看好它。就像，如果我在那个美好的时刻出现在她的脑海里，直到今天我仍然感到内疚。我想知道，你对自己提出这个话题的担忧和顾虑，以及
such a terrible person and like I hadn't fulfilled my duty as a good friend to be excited and supportive and sort of there for her. I worried so much that my feedback had tarnished the moment when he got down on one knee and said, will you marry me? I mean, I worried that I popped into her head. If for even a split second she was thinking, maybe I shouldn't do this because my friend doesn't believe in it. Like, I still to this day feel guilty if that was, if I popped into her head at all in that beautiful moment. I'm wondering if your own worries and concerns about bringing up the topic with her and the
你当时如此焦虑，如此专注于自己的感受，这是否可能让你没能看到那些本可以告诉你关于情况不同之处的线索？绝对是。在寻找她在那次谈话中变得朦胧的眼神时，我看到的是一个正在听我说话，并如此乐于接受这个困难话题的人。我没有看到，哦天哪，她在挣扎。她在挣扎着与我分享他们即将订婚的现实。我想我太专注于自己的观点，
fact that you were so anxious about it and so focused on how you were feeling about it, is it possible that that kept you from seeing the cues that might have actually told you something different about the situation? Absolutely. In searching in her eyes that became misty during that conversation, I saw someone who was listening to me and engaging with me so receptively on this difficult topic. I didn't see, oh gosh, she's struggling. She's struggling to share with me this reality that they are getting engaged imminently. And I think I was too focused on my own perspective
并鼓起勇气提供这种反馈，而没有足够关注她是如何接受它的。[♪ 背景播放轻柔的音乐，伴随着轻柔的钢琴声...] 当我们回来时，为什么对话比我们大多数人意识到的要复杂得多，以及如何提高对话能力。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们大多数人整天都在进行对话，每天都与伴侣、孩子、朋友、
and working up the sort of courage to deliver this feedback and not focused enough on how she was receiving it. [♪ soft music playing in background, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with a soft piano sound and a soft piano sound, with When we come back, why conversations are much more complex than most of us realize, and how to get better at them. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Most of us engage in conversation all day, every day, with partners, children, friends,
同事、邻居交流。然而，尽管有这种不断的练习，我们在与他人交谈方面并不像我们预期的那样熟练。我们误用、误解了别人所说的话，并被尴尬或紧张的时刻所困扰。在哈佛商学院，艾莉森·伍德布鲁克斯研究对话科学，是什么让与一个人的交谈成为一种乐趣，
co-workers, neighbors. Yet, despite all this constant practice, we're not as skilled at talking to others as we might expect. We miscuse, misunderstand what others are saying, and get stymied by moments of awkwardness or tension. At Harvard Business School, Allison Woodbrook studies the science of conversation, what makes talking with one person a joy
而与另一个人的交谈却成为一种苦差事或无聊的事？艾莉森，当你像科学家一样开始剖析对话时，你会意识到它比我们意识到的要复杂得多。你称之为一场复杂的协调游戏，里面隐藏着陷阱和挑战，迷宫般的决策。你这是什么意思？哦，这确实是一场复杂的协调游戏。我们在每次对话的每一刻都在做数百个微小的决定。我们必须协调这些关于我们说什么以及怎么说的微小决定，与另一个人类思维进行协调。然后当我们处于一个有许多其他人类思维的群体中时，他们都在每次对话的每一刻做出自己的微小决定。
and talking with another person a chore or a bore? Allison, when you start to dissect a conversation like a scientist, you realize that it's more complicated than we realize. You call it a complex coordination game with trap doors and challenges hidden inside a maze of decisions. What do you mean by this? Oh, it is such a complicated coordination game. We are making hundreds of micro decisions at every moment of every conversation. And we have to coordinate those micro decisions about what we say and how we say it with another human mind. And then when we're in a group with many other human minds who are all making their own micro decisions at every moment of every conversation.
所以当你开始研究它的科学，观察这些微小瞬间和微小决定时，你也会意识到人类竟然能学会说话，这简直是个奇迹，真的，协调他们的轮流说话，说话和倾听，通过言语和手势分享理解，这真是奇迹。现在，在某些时刻，我想有可能向对方传达，你知道，我觉得对话偏离了轨道，我很伤心，我们能谈谈别的吗？你知道，你不应该告诉我跟我男朋友分手。
So when you start to sort of study the science of it and look at these micro moments and these micro decisions, you also realize that it's a miracle that human beings have figured out how to talk at all, really, to coordinate their turn taking, to speak and listen, to share understanding through their words and their gestures is miraculous. Now, in certain moments, I suppose it's possible to communicate to the other person, you know, I think the conversation is going off the rails, I'm feeling sad, can we talk about something else? You know, you shouldn't be telling me to break up with my boyfriend.
事实上，我正要嫁给他。但在许多情况下，这样做是不合适的。所以谈谈这种增加的复杂性。不仅仅是我们有这些发生的不同事情的巨大复杂性，而且我们实际上无法公开谈论它们。没错。我们不可能就所有这些微小决定进行沟通。讽刺的是，即使在我们互相交谈时，我们也无法真正直接地
In fact, I'm about to get married to him. But in many situations, that's inappropriate to do. So talk about this added complexity. It's not just that we have these huge complexity of different things that are happening, but we can't actually openly talk about them. That's right. We cannot possibly communicate about all of these micro decisions. The irony of it is that even while we're talking to each other, we can't actually communicate
沟通所有这些事情。不仅是因为可行性问题，我们没有足够的时间来沟通所有这些决定，而且我们还有一种对自然性的期望。一场好的对话需要感觉像是你们在没有谈论它的情况下就找到了令人愉快的题目，你们在没有直接沟通的情况下就理解了彼此的思想。这就是魔法所在的地方。过多的直接沟通会很快破坏这种魔法。你看，人们在对话中不如他们可能的那样熟练的一个原因是，他们很少得到关于他们对话
directly about all of these things. Not only for feasibility concerns, we don't have enough time to communicate about all these decisions, but also we have this expectation of sort of naturalness. A good conversation needs to feel like you've alighted on delightful topics without talking about it, that you understand each other's minds without communicating directly about it. That's sort of where the magic lives. And too much direct communication can quickly undermine that magic. You see, one reason people may be less skillful than they could be at conversation is that they rarely get feedback on their conversational
失误和坏习惯的反馈。我回想起你的相亲，你知道，我想这个男人在和你约会之前也去过其他约会，其他女性可能也有和你一样的感觉，但没有人告诉他。没错。在很多方面，他终于遇到了那个能给他提供如此宝贵反馈的合适女性。但在其他方面，有些人会说他和错误的女性约会了，惹错了人。没错。我们只是，得到关于“哦，那个笑话真好笑，或者我真的很喜欢你给我那个赞美，或者嘿，你已经问了，
missteps and bad habits. I'm thinking back to your blind date, you know, I imagine this man had gone on other dates before he went on a date with you and other women may have felt exactly the same way that you did, but no one told him. That's right. In many ways, he finally met the right woman to give him feedback that would be so valuable for him. But in other ways, some would say that he went on a date with the wrong woman, messed with the wrong girl. That's right. We just, it's so rare to get certainly direct feedback about, you know, oh, that joke was really funny, or I really loved when you gave me that compliment, or hey, you've been asked,
你到目前为止问了我16个问题，做得好，或者嘿，你说的那个东西我没太听懂，或者嘿，当你这么说时，它真的伤害了我的感情”的直接反馈太罕见了，我们只是没有时间以那种方式沟通并给出那样的实时反馈，而且这违背了所有人与人之间沟通的规范。我想知道，当涉及到我们的熟人时，这个问题是否实际上加剧了。当我们有一个亲密的朋友、亲戚或伴侣时，也许我们确实会坐下来和他们进行一次谈话，
you've asked me 16 questions so far good for you or hey that thing that you said I didn't quite understand it or hey when you said this it really hurt my feelings we just don't have time to communicate in that way and give live feedback like that and it would just it just goes against all of the sort of norms of human-to-human communication. I'm wondering if the problem is actually compounded when it comes to our acquaintances. When we have a close friend or a relative or a partner, maybe we do sit down and have a conversation with them
关于困扰我们的事情。但我能想到许多熟人，他们说和做的事情让别人感到不舒服，让我感到不舒服。我从来不说任何话，也没有人说任何话。那个人就这样轻快地过着生活，相信他们所说和所做的一切都是好的。当然，我想如果我们走到每个熟人面前说，
about something that's bothering us. But I can think of many acquaintances who say and do things that rub other people the wrong way, that rub me the wrong way. I never say anything, nobody else says anything. And the person goes through life blithely believing that everything they're saying and doing is fine. And of course, I suppose it would be inappropriate for us to go up to every acquaintance and
“我可以给你关于你和人说话方式的反馈吗？”那会显得非常奇怪。但与此同时，这意味着我们大多数人对自己的行为一无所知。没错。没错。而且我认为偶尔你会遇到一个足够勇敢、足够善良的人，真正告诉你，“你知道，嘿，我真的很钦佩你做这件事的时候，或者当你做这件事时它真的伤害了我。”
say, can I give you feedback on the way you're talking to people? That would seem very odd. But at the same time, it means that most of us are left in the dark about how we are behaving. That's right. That's right. And I think every once in a while, you encounter someone who is courageous enough and kind enough to actually tell you, you know, that, hey, I really admired when you did this thing, or it really hurt me when you did this.
但这需要如此不可思议的星象排列，以及一个非常熟练的人，才能以一种不让人觉得过于个人化、过于威胁的方式提供反馈。它还需要一段非常稳固的关系。你们必须真正信任彼此，才能对某人说出如此脆弱的话。让我们看看破坏对话的一些陷阱。一个是，我们陷入了一种闲聊的炼狱。
But it takes such an incredible array of sort of stars to align and a very skilled person to be able to deliver feedback in a way that doesn't feel overly personal, overly threatening. It also requires a really sturdy relationship. You have to really trust each other in order to be able to say something so vulnerable to someone. Let's look at some of the trap doors that undermine conversation. One is that we get stuck in a kind of purgatory of small talk.
你在最近的一个万圣节陷入了这样一个对话死循环。告诉我们发生了什么，艾莉森。是的，即使是对话教授也无法免受闲聊的危险。我想说，大约每周一次，我会进行一次对话，心想：“哇，我真的，我在那里的闲聊搞砸了。”这次对话，我们带着我们的三个孩子出去，不给糖就捣蛋。那是一个异常温暖的夜晚。
You entered one such conversational doom loop on a recent Halloween. Tell me what happened, Allison. Yes, even a professor of conversation is not immune from the perils of small talk. About once a week, I would say, I have a conversation where I think, wow, I really, I messed up small talk there. This conversation, we were taking our three children out, trick or treating. It was an unseasonably warm night.
天气很好。我们有一个很棒的平坦社区，我们在那里走来走去，孩子们不给糖就捣蛋，得到糖果。我们加入了其他一些家庭一起去。我们认识大多数其他家庭，但有两个家庭我们以前没见过。所以，当我们在那个美丽的夜晚走来走去，看着我们可爱的孩子们捡起巨大的糖果棒时，我与其中一位邻居，这些家庭成员中的一位，开始了对话，
It was beautiful. We have a wonderful flat neighborhood where we walk around and the kids trick or treat and get candy. And we joined up with a number of other families to go together. And we knew most of the other families, but there were two families we had not met before. So at some point, as we're walking around on this beautiful night, watching our adorable kids pick up enormous candy bars, I strike up a conversation with one of the neighbors, one of these family members that
我以前不认识。那是一个来自俄亥俄州的男人。我无意中听到他说他来自俄亥俄州。所以当我们两人变得孤立时，我很快开始问关于俄亥俄州的问题。你是俄亥俄州哪里的？你上过俄亥俄州立大学吗？哦，我去过德国村。那是哥伦布市一个非常古朴的地方。
I didn't know before. And it was a man from Ohio. I overheard him saying that he was from Ohio. And so as the two of us became isolated, I quickly started asking questions about Ohio. Where are you from in Ohio? Did you go to Ohio State? Oh, I've been to German Village. It's such a quaint part of Columbus.
所以我利用我所有的俄亥俄州知识来寻找进入这次对话的方法。我丈夫来自密歇根州，所以我开始谈论十大联盟足球或俄亥俄州立大学与密歇根大学之间的竞争。我真的很努力。但真的，无论我关于俄亥俄州说什么，似乎我们都找不到出路。我们有点被困住了。我们被困在俄亥俄州了。
So I'm using all of my Ohio knowledge to kind of find a way into this conversation. My husband's from Michigan, so I started talking about Big Ten football or the rivalry between Ohio State and Michigan. And I'm really going for it. But really, no matter what I say about Ohio, it doesn't seem like we can find a way out of it. We're sort of stuck. We're stuck in Ohio.
你被困在俄亥俄州了。我们被困在俄亥俄州了。他并没有在回答我的问题时给我很多回应。我把它归结为一种闲聊失败，我说：“你知道吗，我想我会在晚上晚些时候再试着和这个家伙聊聊。”所以从某种程度上说，我听到的是，艾莉森，这个家伙可能是你多年前那次相亲的温和版本，你知道。他也不是很对你的生活感到好奇。
You're trapped in Ohio. We're trapped in Ohio. He's not really giving me a lot in response to my questions. And I chalked it up to a sort of small talk failure and I said, you know what, I think I'm going to try again with this guy later in the night. So in some ways, what I'm hearing, Allison, is that this guy might have been a milder version of the blind date you went on, you know, many years earlier. He also was not very curious about what was going on in your life.
他也是一个没有问你很多问题的人。我理解你对提问的重视源于一个涉及你母亲的背景故事。绝对是。我妈妈是一位了不起的直觉心理学家。当我年轻的时候，可能从初中后期开始，但绝对是高中，我们开车从社交活动回家，她经常问我们：“嘿，你和任何一个非常擅长提问的人谈过话吗？”
He also was someone who was not asking you many questions. I understand that the value that you place on question asking stems from a backstory involving your mom. Absolutely. My mom is an amazing sort of intuitive psychologist. And when I was young, probably starting in late middle school, but definitely high school, we would drive home from social engagements and she would often ask us, hey, did you talk to anybody who was a really good question-asker?
我很感激我妈妈。这让我对人际动态产生了兴趣。你认识了一位名叫瑞秋·格林沃尔德的专业媒人，她对那些缺乏对话好奇心的人有一个很好的术语。告诉我关于她的事，艾莉森。是的，瑞秋·格林沃尔德，我觉得她很棒。她是专业媒人中的大人物。她以媒人身份开始职业生涯，然后她取得了巨大的成功，以至于她
And I'm grateful to my mom for that. It made me sort of pique my interest in interpersonal dynamics. You've gotten to know a professional matchmaker named Rachel Greenwald, and she has a great term for people who lack conversational curiosity. Tell me about her, Allison. Yes, Rachel Greenwald, I think she's amazing. She's sort of the grand pooba of professional matchmakers. She started out her career as a matchmaker and then she had so much success that she
开始培训其他媒人做这份工作。她对我说，我们有一个词来形容那些不问问题的人。当你想到那些一个问题都不问的人，特别是在约会时，我们称他们为ZQ，零提问者（Zero Questioners）。有这样一句话，她说：“你知道，他们说好奇心害死猫，但在约会中，好奇心不会害死约会。事实上，ZQ会害死约会。”所以你有IQ，你有EQ，现在你有ZQ。没错。
started training other matchmakers to do this job. And she said to me, we have a phrase for people who don't ask questions. When you think of people who ask zero questions, especially on a date, we call them ZQs, zero questioners. And there's this quote, she says, you know, they say curiosity killed the cat, but on a date curiosity does not kill the date. In fact, the ZQ kills the date. So you have IQ, you have EQ, and now you have ZQ. That's right.
所以有一个更阴险的相同问题的形式。在这里，那个人确实问了问题，但这些问题并非源于对对方的好奇心。你称之为“回旋镖提问”（Boomer asking）。什么是回旋镖提问，艾莉森？回旋镖提问不是指50岁以上的人问问题。它是以回旋镖的弧线命名的。所以想象你正在扔一个回旋镖，回旋镖有这个弧线，它飞出去，
So there's a more insidious form of the same problem. And here the person does ask questions, but the questions do not stem from curiosity about the other person. You call this boomer asking. What is boomer asking, Allison? Boomer asking is not people over 50 who ask questions. It's named after the arc of a boomerang. And so imagine you're throwing a boomerang and the boomerang has this arc that goes out
然后绕回来，直接回到你身边。回旋镖提问的结构是，你问你的伴侣一个问题，让他们回答这个问题，但随后你把对话的焦点直接带回你自己身上。所以就好像我对你说：“尚卡尔，你的周末过得怎么样？”
and then comes around and comes right back to you. And the structure of boomerasking is you ask a question to your partner, you let them answer the question, but then you bring the focus of the conversation right back to yourself. So it would be as if I said to you, Shankar, how was your weekend?
然后我说：“哦，周末很有趣。我们去了一家不错的餐厅，在公园里散步。哦，好吧，我实际上和哈里·斯泰尔斯去跳伞了，这太棒了。”所以你让你的伴侣回答，但随后你几乎忽略了他们与你分享的内容，你把焦点直接带回你自己身上。这让你的伴侣觉得你根本对他们的回答不感兴趣。你问问题只是为了引出你自己的披露。
And I say, oh, the weekend was fun. We went to a nice restaurant and went for a walk in the park. Oh, well, I actually went skydiving with Harry Styles and it was terrific. So you let your partner answer, but then you almost ignore what they share with you and you bring the focus right back to yourself. It makes your partner feel like you weren't interested in their answer in the first place. You were just asking as a way to set up your own disclosure.
这是一种掩盖你自私、自我中心的一种薄薄的伪装。对话中还有另一个陷阱，可能对许多人来说很熟悉。我想给你播放一段1993年电影《韦恩的世界2》的片段，韦恩和加斯正在接受一位电台主持人的采访，谈论他们很兴奋的一场大型音乐会。好的，我们现在的特别嘉宾，韦恩·坎贝尔，加斯·埃尔加，韦恩的世界，韦恩的世界。好的。谈论韦恩音乐节。他们很兴奋的一场大型音乐会。我只是想提醒大家，还有很多票没卖完。嗯哼，但这并不是拖到最后一分钟的理由。嗯哼，因为这只是奥罗拉市做点什么的机会。嗯哼
It's a sort of thinly veiled way to hide your own selfishness, your own egocentrism. There's another trap door in conversations that might be familiar to many people. I want to play you a clip from the 1993 movie Wayne's World 2, where Wayne and Garth are being interviewed by a radio host about a big concert they are excited about. All right, our special guest right now, Wayne Campbell, Garth Elgar, Wayne's World, Wayne's World. All right. Talking about Wayne stock. big concert they are excited about. I just want to remind everybody that there's still plenty of tickets left Uh-huh, but that's no reason to wait till the last minute Uh-huh because it's just a chance for the city of Aurora To do something. Uh-huh
有趣，嗯哼，并让这座城市出名。嗯哼。这需要很多工作。哦，好吧，哈哈，工作很辛苦。你并没有真正在听我说话，对吧？嗯哼。我的意思是，我现在可以说任何话，比如你是个彻头彻尾的工具人。但你不会听到的。所以艾莉森，人们在对话中不听对方说话的情况有多频繁？哦，尚卡尔，这种情况一直都在发生。我认为这个片段对我们来说之所以这么好笑，是因为它太有共鸣了。
Fun, uh-huh and to put the city on the map. Mm-hmm. It's a lot of work Oh, well, haha work is hard. You're not really listening to me, are you? Uh-huh. I mean, I could say anything right now, like you're a complete tool. But you wouldn't hear it. So Allison, how often is it that people in conversation fail to listen to one another? Oh, Shankar, this happens all the time. I think the reason this clip is so funny to us is because it's so relatable.
我们最近的研究表明，人们的思绪在对话中24%的时间都在游离。这是基于他们自己的自我报告。所以我们在对话中每五分钟打断他们一次，问他们：“你在专心听你的伴侣说话，还是你的思绪在游离？”24%的时间他们说：“实际上我的思绪在游离。我没在听我的伴侣说话。”我们怀疑这是一个低估，因为人们知道，不听伴侣说话
We have done research recently to show that people's minds are wandering 24% of the time during conversation. And this was based on their own self-reports. So we interrupted them every five minutes in a conversation and asked them, were you listening attentively to your partner or was your mind wandering? And 24% of the time they say, actually my mind was wandering. I wasn't listening to my partner. We suspect this is an underestimate because people know that it's sort of embarrassing
有点尴尬。你会在视频通话或Zoom上看到这种情况。人们对着摄像头微笑和点头，即使他们同时在旁边给朋友发短信或列购物清单。因为有这些礼貌规范，对吧？我们知道我们应该让我们的伴侣觉得我们在听他们说话。对于我们大多数人来说，说话似乎并不难。
to not be listening to their partner. You see this happen during video calls or like on Zoom. People are smiling and nodding at the camera even while they're like to the side texting their friend or making a grocery list. Because there are these norms of politeness, right? We know that we should make our partners feel like we're listening to them. For most of us, talking doesn't seem hard.
我们张开嘴，话就出来了。但当我们经历人生时，通常情况是，我们周围的人并没有在我们让他们感到无聊、恼火或仅仅是冒犯时告诉我们。当我们回来时，如何让我们的对话更具吸引力？你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我对新冠疫情爆发前的一次伟大对话有着生动的记忆。
We open our mouths and words come out. But as we go through life, it is usually the case that the people around us are not telling us when they find us boring or irritating or just plain offensive. When we come back, how to make our conversations more engaging? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. I have a vivid memory of a great conversation right before the COVID pandemic struck.
我当时坐在新奥尔良的一家餐厅里，和四位来参加心理学会议的研究人员在一起。对话感觉就像一场快速的乒乓球比赛。感觉毫不费力。太棒了。在哈佛商学院，艾莉森·伍德布鲁克斯站在大厅里。对话感觉就像一场快速的乒乓球比赛。感觉毫不费力。太棒了。在哈佛商学院，艾莉森·伍德布鲁克斯研究我们所有人如何能进行更多令人难忘的对话。她是《谈话：对话科学与做自己的艺术》一书的作者。艾莉森，我有一个强烈的信念，即真实的对话
I was sitting in a New Orleans restaurant with four researchers who were in town to attend a psychology conference. The conversation felt like a rapid-fire game of ping-pong. It felt effortless. It was glorious. At Harvard Business School, Alison Woodbrook stood in the hall. The conversation felt like a rapid-fire game of ping-pong. It felt effortless. It was glorious. At Harvard Business School, Allison Woodbrook studies how we can all have many more memorable conversations. She is the author of Talk, The Science of Conversation, and The Art of Being Ourselves. Allison, I have a strong belief that authentic conversations
必须自然而然地产生。我怀疑许多听众也有同样的信念，即真实的对话必须自然而然地产生，我怀疑许多听众也有同样的信念。你说这是一个错误。没错。我们经常谈论这个“自然性神话”的想法。我的许多学生和许多人都相信，好的对话者是天生的，他们外向、合群、有魅力，这就是他们的样子。这是他们的个性。
must just emerge naturally. And I suspect many listeners have the same belief that authentic conversations must just emerge naturally, and I suspect many listeners have the same belief. You say this is a mistake. That's right. We often talk about this idea of the myth of naturalness. So many of my students and so many people believe that good conversationalists are born, that they are extroverted and gregarious and charismatic and that's just how they are. It's their personality.
但我过去15年所做的大量工作表明，关于对话的许多、许多事情都是非常可学的。即使对于那些认为自己天生没有魅力的最内向、害羞、笨拙的人来说，这些事情也是可以学习的。我们在研究和课堂中学到的最有价值的事情之一就是“话题准备”的概念。话题准备实际上只是在对话开始前思考
But so much of the work that I've done over the last 15 years suggests that many, many things about conversation are very learnable. Even for the most introverted, shy, awkward people who really think that they weren't born charismatic, these things can be learned as well. And one of the most valuable things that we've learned in our research and in my class is this idea of topic preparation. Topic preparation is literally just thinking about
我们可以谈论哪些可能的话题。这并不复杂。许多人发现这种为对话做准备的想法，特别是对于工作之外我们亲近的人，是非常令人反感的。你有一种本能，认为我不应该需要为与我亲近的人的对话做准备。我们会聚在一起，我会确切地知道谈论什么，或者我们会谈论很多事情。我的许多学生也有这种感觉。
what are possible things that we could talk about before the conversation begins. It's not complex. And many people find this idea of preparing for a conversation, especially for people that we're close to outside of work, to be very aversive. You sort of have this instinct that I shouldn't need to prepare for a conversation with someone that I'm close to. We'll get together and I'll know exactly what to talk about or we'll have many things to talk about. And many of my students feel this way too.
他们有点像：“你为什么要让我为一次随意的谈话做准备？”在某些方面，我们在工作环境中确实在某种程度上这样做，对吧？所以我们可以开个会，例如，会议前会分发议程，说明我们要谈论什么。
They're sort of like, why are you making me prepare for a casual conversation? And in some ways, we do this to some extent in work settings, right? So we can have a meeting, for example, and there's an agenda that's circulated before the meeting saying, here's what we're going to talk about.
但这在工作环境中似乎是可以的，而在个人环境中却似乎很难做到。是的，这在工作环境中稍微更规范、更常见，在那里提前有议程更常见，或者至少有人考虑过它。虽然，你可能会惊讶于即使在工作环境中它也是多么罕见。几年前我和谷歌合作，他们在谷歌内部开展了这项巨大的运动。唯一的目的就是让人们即使提前一点点思考他们的会议。比如，他们有这样一个问题，人们只是出现而没有提前思考，以至于他们
But that seems okay in work settings in ways that it seems difficult to do in personal settings. Yeah, it's slightly more normative, more common in work settings where it's more common to have an agenda ahead of time or at least somebody has thought about it. Although, you might be surprised by how rare it is even in work settings. I was working with Google a few years ago who had this huge campaign within Google. And the only goal was to get people to think ahead about their meetings even a little bit. Like they had such a problem with people just showing up and not thinking ahead that they
但这在工作环境中似乎是可以接受的，而在个人生活中却很难做到。是的，这在工作环境中更规范、更常见，因为在工作中有预先设定的议程，或者至少有人提前考虑过，这更普遍。尽管你可能会惊讶，即使在工作环境中，这种情况也相当罕见。几年前我和谷歌合作时，他们内部开展了一项大型活动，唯一的目标就是让人们在开会前哪怕稍微思考一下。他们当时面临的问题是，人们总是毫无准备地去开会，这让他们非常头疼。
started this huge campaign. So even at work, I think there is sort of a resistance to topic prep or at least a lack of making time to think ahead about our conversations. And certainly in casual conversations, people feel like they don't need to and so they don't. So you have found that topic preparation can be helpful even when we're talking with someone who is close to us. You recently met up with a very good friend of yours, and she had an unusual proposition for you that involved the singer Whitney Houston.
发起了这项大型活动。所以即使在工作中，我认为人们对准备话题也存在某种抵触情绪，或者至少缺乏时间去提前思考我们的对话。当然，在随意的交谈中，人们觉得没必要这样做，所以他们也就没做。所以你发现，即使是在与亲近的人交谈时，准备话题也会有所帮助。你最近见了一位非常好的朋友，她向你提出了一个不同寻常的建议，涉及歌手惠特尼·休斯顿。
That's right. This story is surprisingly, um, sort of tender and important to me. It is a friend that I'd spent many years singing in a band with. She's this talented, wonderful friend. And we had both started having children. And after she had her first child, she became sick. And it was just it was devastating. And meanwhile, I had my own baby, so I wasn't even available to go and visit her very often. And so this conversation when we got together felt so momentous. It felt like we needed to catch up
没错。这个故事出人意料地，嗯，对我来说既温柔又重要。那是我曾一起在乐队里唱过多年歌的朋友。她是一位才华横溢、非常棒的朋友。我们俩都开始有了孩子。在她生下第一个孩子后，她生病了。这简直是毁灭性的打击。与此同时，我也有了自己的孩子，所以我甚至没法经常去探望她。所以当我们聚在一起时，这次谈话感觉意义重大。感觉我们像是需要叙叙旧，
on so many things about this incredibly difficult period of her life. And brilliant woman that she is, not only had she prepared topics and really thought carefully about all the things we needed to catch up on together in our limited time together, but she had given each topic a Whitney Houston song title. It really almost makes me cry thinking of it. It was so thoughtful and so fun in such sort of dire circumstances. And so she had prepped topics like Whitney Houston's song, Higher Love. She said, when was the last time you took your baby on an airplane and how terrible was it? Or the Whitney Houston song, Run to You. I think it's Run to You, Run to Me.
聊聊她生命中这段极其艰难时期的许多事情。而且她是一位才华横溢的女性，她不仅准备了话题，还非常仔细地思考了我们在有限的相聚时间里需要叙旧的所有事情，甚至还给每个话题都起了一个惠特尼·休斯顿的歌名。想到这一点，我几乎要流泪了。在那种可怕的情况下，这显得如此体贴又如此有趣。所以她准备了像惠特尼·休斯顿的歌《Higher Love》这样的话题。她说，你上次带孩子坐飞机是什么时候？有多糟糕？或者惠特尼·休斯顿的歌《Run to You》。我想应该是《Run to You》，《Run to Me》。
And she said, you know, are you still running? Right? Like, what's your running regimen these days? And so she had just, it was just so thoughtful and so like her to make, to prep topics at all and to show me that she was thinking about us even when we were apart. And then to bump it up even another notch and give him these Whitney Houston song titles. And I'm wondering, were you singing along when each topic changed and each new song had to be played or came up? We did play some of the songs and she is the most miraculous, beautiful singer. Due to her sickness, she wasn't able to sing, but I do have an
她说，你知道，你还在跑步吗？对吧？比如，你最近的跑步计划是什么？所以她只是，这太体贴了，而且非常像她的风格，竟然会去准备话题，并向我展示即使在我们分开时她也在想着我们。更进一步的是，还给这些话题起了惠特尼·休斯顿的歌名。我想知道，当每个话题转换、每首新歌播放或出现时，你有没有跟着唱？我们确实播放了一些歌曲，她是那种最奇迹、最美妙的歌手。由于生病，她无法唱歌，但我确实有一段
incredible video that I will save and cherish forever where she's lip-syncing along with this Whitney Houston song and it's just divine. One of the greatest moments of my life. So, no matter how well we've planned and chosen our topic, eventually, you know, conversation subjects can run out of juice. Your research has found that switching topics frequently can make for better conversation. Yeah, so we ran these studies and we wanted to find out what's better? Should we stay on one topic and try and get very deep? Or is it better to switch topics frequently?
令人难以置信的视频，我会永远保存并珍藏，视频里她跟着这首惠特尼·休斯顿的歌对口型，简直太神圣了。这是我一生中最伟大的时刻之一。所以，无论我们计划得多么周密、话题选得多么好，最终，你知道，谈话的主题可能会失去活力。你的研究发现，频繁转换话题可以带来更好的对话。是的，我们进行了这些研究，我们想找出什么更好？我们应该坚持一个话题并尝试深入探讨吗？还是频繁转换话题更好？
The best conversationalists do switch topics more frequently, but as soon as they land on a new topic, they get deep on it quite quickly by asking a lot of questions. And so they're actually doing both. It's not a trade-off between depth and breadth. You should be aiming to do both, and you should be keeping your hand on the sort of temperature gauge of the conversation. As soon as a topic seems like it's running out of juice, you should be unafraid and confident and switch to something else to keep the conversation fun and interesting and fizzing along. And what if you feel like the conversation is fizzling out, but you're worried that maybe other people find the conversation really interesting and so you're hesitant to jump
最优秀的谈话者确实会更频繁地转换话题，但一旦他们进入一个新话题，他们会通过提出大量问题迅速深入探讨。所以他们实际上两者兼顾。这并不是深度和广度之间的权衡。你应该以两者兼顾为目标，并且你应该保持对谈话“温度计”的掌控。一旦某个话题看起来快要失去活力，你应该无所畏惧、充满自信地切换到其他话题，以保持谈话的乐趣、趣味性和活跃度。如果觉得谈话正在逐渐冷场，但又担心别人可能觉得谈话很有趣，所以犹豫着不敢插话
in and change the topic? Yeah, this is a very common feeling. We worry about being rude. I think politeness is a major reason that we sort of hesitate and hold back on switching topics. Our fears of being rude, what we find in our research, are overblown. One of the beautiful things about conversation
去转换话题怎么办？是的，这是一种非常普遍的感觉。我们担心显得粗鲁。我认为礼貌是我们犹豫不决、不敢转换话题的主要原因。我们在研究中发现，我们对显得粗鲁的恐惧是被夸大了。对话的美妙之处之一在于
is that you can always come back to the topic. You can come back to the topic later in the conversation. You can come back to it later in your relationship in a different conversation. The bigger risk is staying too long and stagnating. So you've created a tool called the Topic Pyramid to help people map out where they are in conversations and where to take conversations. What is the Topic Pyramid, Allison? The Topic Pyramid is a tool that I realized that my students needed so badly, and I think
你总是可以回到原来的话题。你可以在谈话的后期回到那个话题。你可以在以后的不同谈话中回到它。更大的风险是停留太久而陷入停滞。所以你创建了一个名为“话题金字塔”的工具，来帮助人们规划他们在谈话中的位置以及谈话的走向。艾莉森，什么是话题金字塔？话题金字塔是我意识到我的学生非常需要，而且我认为
everyone needs so badly. There are three levels to the pyramid. At the base of the pyramid, this is where small talk lives. These are topics that you could talk about with anyone. So how's the, what about this weather? How was your weekend? What are you excited about? You know, what's going on at the weekend coming up? Those sort of well-trodden, well-known small talk topics.
每个人都非常需要的工具。金字塔有三个层次。金字塔的底部是闲聊所在的地方。这些是你和任何人都可以谈论的话题。比如天气怎么样？周末过得如何？你对什么感到兴奋？你知道，即将到来的周末有什么安排？那些陈词滥调、众所周知的闲聊话题。
It's totally okay to be at the bottom of the pyramid. In fact, many conversations have to start there. It's this well-trodden ground, especially with strangers or with people you haven't seen in a long time. You have to start there. That's part of the norm of conversation. The mistake is staying at the base of the pyramid too long and letting it stagnate and become dull. And that's when these alarm bells go off in your mind where you say, oh my, we got to get out of this.
停留在金字塔底部完全没问题。事实上，许多谈话必须从那里开始。这是必经之路，尤其是与陌生人或很久没见的人交谈时。你必须从那里开始。这是谈话规范的一部分。错误在于在金字塔底部停留太久，让它停滞并变得沉闷。那时你脑海中的警钟就会响起，你会说，天哪，我们得摆脱这种状态。
We got to get to something more meaningful. So the second tier of the pyramid is what we call medium talk or tailored talk, where you're moving towards a topic that is more interesting, more personal, and closer maybe to what your partner has in terms of interests and expertise. So it's becoming more personalized. The third, the top tier of the pyramid, is deep talk. Deep talk is what friends and family members and work besties, this is what we're all hungry for the type of conversation to have with people we're very close to.
我们得聊点更有意义的事情。所以金字塔的第二层是我们所说的“中层谈话”或“定制谈话”，在这里你转向一个更有趣、更个人化，可能更贴近你谈话对象兴趣和专业领域的话题。所以它变得更加个性化了。第三层，也就是金字塔的顶层，是“深度谈话”。深度谈话是朋友、家人和工作伙伴所渴望的，这是我们都渴望与非常亲近的人进行的谈话类型。
It's a sort of unique place of shared reality where maybe only the two of you could be talking about this topic in this way. And so not every conversation needs to get to the peak. That's not always the goal. When your neighbor is just taking out their trash, you don't need to get to the peak. That's not always the goal. When your neighbor is just taking out their trash, you don't need to get to the peak of the pyramid necessarily. The key here is fostering a little bit more of an awareness of where you are in the pyramid and making sure that you don't get stuck
这是一种独特的共享现实空间，也许只有你们两个人能以这种方式谈论这个话题。所以并不是每次谈话都需要达到顶峰。那并不总是目标。当你的邻居只是在倒垃圾时，你不需要达到顶峰。那并不总是目标。当你的邻居只是在倒垃圾时，你不需要达到金字塔的顶峰。这里的关键是培养对你在金字塔中所处位置的更多意识，并确保你不会被困在
at the base of the pyramid for too long. We talked about the importance of asking questions. One of the things that you and others have found is the importance of asking open-ended questions. Describe what these questions are, Allison, and why they have such a powerful effect in conversations. That's right. Our work suggests that asking more questions is like the sort of baseline best thing that
金字塔底部太久。我们谈到了提问的重要性。你和其他人发现的一件事是提出开放式问题的重要性。艾莉森，描述一下这些问题是什么，以及为什么它们在谈话中具有如此强大的效果。没错。我们的研究表明，多提问就像是你生活中能做的最基础、最好的事情，
you can do in your life to get better at question asking, just ask more. But there's a lot of nuance in the types of questions that are better and worse in certain circumstances. So open-ended questions, invite your partner to share, right? These are questions are like, what's on your mind or what was your morning like? What are you excited about lately? These questions that are born of curiosity
为了提高提问能力，多问就行了。但在某些情况下，问题的类型有很多细微差别，有好有坏。所以开放式问题邀请你的伙伴分享，对吧？这些问题就像是，你心里在想什么？或者你早上过得怎么样？你最近对什么感到兴奋？这些源于好奇心的问题
that invite your partner to share their perspective with you. Whereas closed-ended questions, as many of us know, usually have a very distinct answer. So, do you like how this conversation is going? Did you sleep well last night? These sort of yes, no questions are very closed. And so in our research, what we found is open-ended questions are so powerful because your partner
邀请你的伙伴与你分享他们的观点。而封闭式问题，正如我们许多人所知，通常有一个非常明确的答案。所以，你喜欢这次谈话的进展吗？你昨晚睡得好吗？这些是非题是非常封闭的。所以在我们的研究中，我们发现开放式问题非常强大，因为你的伙伴
answers in more than twice the word count compared to closed-ended questions. This is powerful in any conversation, but particularly in conflictual conversations or when you're negotiating and we where learning information about your counterpart is so pivotal, asking an open-ended question like, what do you care about? Or what's important to you here? You're going to learn so much more information about their perspective and their needs and their motives and their positions than, will you accept this offer? Now, you've actually studied negotiations, and of course, negotiations in some ways are one particular form of conversation.
回答的字数是封闭式问题的两倍多。这在任何谈话中都很强大，但在冲突性谈话或谈判中尤其如此，当我们了解对方的信息至关重要时，提出一个开放式问题，比如，你在乎什么？或者这里对你来说什么很重要？你将比问“你会接受这个提议吗？”学到更多关于他们的观点、需求、动机和立场的信息。现在，你实际上研究过谈判，当然，谈判在某种程度上是一种特殊的谈话形式。
And you find that negotiators, in fact, do not ask enough open-ended questions? That's right. When we studied question asking among negotiators, what we found is that only nine percent of turns across hundreds of conversations included open-ended questions. And this is a huge mistake. Open-ended questions are the most direct pathway to extract information from your counterpart because they're going to answer you in a much more open-ended way. You've also found that it's very powerful to ask follow-up questions. Why is this a good idea, Alison? Besides the fact that it's just more questions, asking a follow-up question that's connected to a previous question and answer, why is that so powerful? Follow-up questions are superheroes.
你发现谈判者实际上并没有提出足够的开放式问题？没错。当我们研究谈判者之间的提问时，我们发现数百次谈话中只有9%的轮次包含了开放式问题。这是一个巨大的错误。开放式问题是从对方那里获取信息的最直接途径，因为他们会以更开放的方式回答你。你还发现提出后续问题非常强大。艾莉森，为什么这是一个好主意？除了它只是更多的问题之外，提出一个与之前的问题和答案相关联的后续问题，为什么它如此强大？后续问题是超级英雄。
They are amazing. When we studied 1,100 speed dates, so people going on these four-minute speed dates, what we found is that people who asked more questions were more likely to get second dates, so their partners were more likely to say yes to them, so much so that if you asked just one more question on each of your 20 dates, you would convert one more of your dates into a yes.
它们太棒了。当我们研究了1100次快速约会，也就是人们进行的这些四分钟的快速约会时，我们发现提问更多的人更有可能获得第二次约会，所以他们的伙伴更有可能对他们说“是”，以至于如果你在20次约会中每次多问一个问题，你就会将多一次约会转化为“是”。
Wow. One question on each date. And what we found when we dove into the actual language that people were using and the types of questions people were asking, we realized that this effect was driven almost entirely by follow-up questions. So follow-up questions, follow-up on anything that your partner has said previously. The reason they're so powerful is because they're an undeniable indicator that you have listened to your partner, right? You ask them a question, you let them answer, and you heard their answer and you want to know more.
哇。每次约会多问一个问题。当我们深入研究人们使用的实际语言和人们提出的问题类型时，我们意识到这种效果几乎完全是由后续问题驱动的。所以后续问题，跟进你的伙伴之前说过的任何事情。它们之所以如此强大，是因为它们是你已经倾听了伙伴的不可否认的标志，对吧？你问他们一个问题，让他们回答，你听到了他们的回答，并且你想知道更多。
So people who study intimate and close relationships call this responsiveness. So follow-up questions show that you are being responsive to your partner and that you're curious to know more. I want to play you a bit of tape featuring two people having a conversation. This is the late night host Stephen Colbert and the news anchor Anderson Cooper. Both these men of course are gifted communicators, but both also experience the loss of people close to them and they're talking here about the nature of grief. I think when you meet someone who's had a loss, you have two options. One is to say I'm sorry for your loss, which is a perfectly lovely thing to do.
所以研究亲密关系的人称这为“响应性”。所以后续问题表明你对你的伙伴有响应，并且你有好奇心想知道更多。我想给你播放一段两个人在谈话的录音。这是深夜脱口秀主持人斯蒂芬·科尔伯特和新闻主播安德森·库珀。这两个人当然都是天才的沟通者，但两人也都经历过失去亲人的痛苦，他们在这里谈论悲伤的本质。我认为当你遇到一个经历过失去的人时，你有两个选择。一个是说我对你的损失感到抱歉，这是一种非常可爱的做法。
But if you can share your experience, then they're not alone. Well, it's always interesting to me how when you bring it up, meeting somebody for the first time and they say, I'm sorry to bring it up, you know, and as if what they don't realize is, I'm thinking about it all the time. I mean, it is, as you said, it is, you know, it's one of my arms. I mean, it is an extension of who I am.
但如果你能分享你的经历，那么他们就不孤单了。嗯，对我来说总是很有趣，当你提起这件事时，第一次见到某人，他们说，我很抱歉提起这件事，你知道，好像他们没有意识到的是，我一直在想这件事。我的意思是，正如你所说，它是，你知道，它是我的一条手臂。我的意思是，它是我是谁的一部分延伸。
Quite possibly for the rest of your life. Oh, without a doubt. Alison, what do you hear when you listen to this conversation? This is a beautiful conversation. You can hear their mutual engagement, and Anderson Cooper is sharing a story about his own loss, his own grief,
很可能伴随你的余生。哦，毫无疑问。艾莉森，当你听这段谈话时，你听到了什么？这是一段美丽的谈话。你可以听到他们相互的投入，安德森·库珀正在分享关于他自己的损失、他自己的悲伤的故事，
but it feels like Stephen Colbert is helping him tell this story. And it's a phenomenon that psychologists call co-narration, where someone is listening so intently and they're working in tandem in the conversation so well that they're finishing each other's sentences. It's like your conversation partner is helping you deliver the story. They're co-narrating the story with you. And it's a signal of excellent, involved, attentive listening and trust and relationship closeness.
但感觉斯蒂芬·科尔伯特正在帮助他讲述这个故事。这是心理学家称之为“共同叙事”的现象，即某人听得如此专注，他们在谈话中配合得如此默契，以至于他们能接上对方的话。就像你的谈话伙伴在帮你传达故事。他们正在和你一起共同叙述这个故事。这是优秀的、投入的、专注的倾听以及信任和关系亲密的信号。
And it's wonderful to listen to. I mean, you could also say, of course, that they are talking over each other. And many of us, I think, were raised to believe that it's rude to interrupt another person. But in some ways, as I listen to this, I'm not hearing rudeness at all. I am hearing, as you say, co-creation of the story that Anderson Cooper is telling Stephen Colbert. It's very important to think about interruptions
听起来很棒。我的意思是，你也可以说，当然，他们是在互相打断。我认为我们许多人从小就被教导打断别人是不礼貌的。但在某种程度上，当我听这段录音时，我一点也没觉得粗鲁。我听到的是，正如你所说，安德森·库珀正在向斯蒂芬·科尔伯特讲述的故事的共同创造。思考打断非常重要
in two different ways. The first way is on-topic interruption. Here we hear Colbert and Cooper, they are very much in the midst of a deep and meaningful topic and they are not going anywhere. Stephen Colbert is not trying to change the subject. In fact, he is like going deeper and deeper with Anderson on this topic.
以两种不同的方式。第一种方式是“话题内打断”。在这里我们听到科尔伯特和库珀，他们非常沉浸在一个深刻而有意义的话题中，他们哪里也不会去。斯蒂芬·科尔伯特并没有试图转换话题。事实上，他正在和安德森在这个话题上越挖越深。
So it's really, these are, they're finishing each other's sentences, but they're also on-topic interruptions as opposed to the type of interruptions that nobody likes, which are off-topic interruptions. It's that you're switching, you're sort of ignoring what someone is saying and you're switching to something completely new. And that feels so abrupt, so rude, and often sort of hurtful and annoying. There is another conversational move that can bring us closer to others. And you saw this when you and a friend went to a party hosted by another friend named Dave. Can you tell me that story, Allison? Yes, this is back in college. This character we'll call Dave was well known for being very charming.
所以这确实是，他们是在接对方的话，但他们也是话题内打断，而不是那种没人喜欢的打断，即“话题外打断”。那就是你转换了话题，你有点忽略了别人在说什么，而你切换到了一个全新的话题。这感觉太突兀、太粗鲁，而且往往有点伤人和烦人。还有另一种可以让我们更接近他人的谈话举动。当你和一个朋友去参加另一个叫戴夫的朋友举办的聚会时，你看到了这一点。艾莉森，你能告诉我那个故事吗？是的，那是大学时代。这个我们称之为戴夫的角色以非常有魅力而闻名。
And a girlfriend and I went to this party and Dave was greeting everyone at the door and we walk into the party and Dave turns to me and he says, Allison, you're so beautiful. So you look so beautiful tonight. So beautiful. Welcome. Come on in. Come on in and he turns to my girlfriend and And says oh Claire you look so beautiful. So beautiful tonight unbelievable And we sort of we say thank you Dave. Thank you so much
我和一个女朋友去参加了这个聚会，戴夫在门口迎接每个人，我们走进聚会，戴夫转向我说，艾莉森，你太美了。你今晚看起来太美了。太美了。欢迎。进来吧。进来吧，然后他转向我的女朋友说，哦，克莱尔，你看起来太美了。今晚太美了，难以置信。我们有点，我们说谢谢戴夫。非常感谢。
And we walk up off into the party and as more people are arriving at the door you hear him going through this sort of And as more people are arriving at the door, you hear him going through this sort of flattery schtick over and over. Every person that comes in, oh, you're so beautiful. It's not even constrained to just the women, right? To the many, oh, you look so handsome. You look so great tonight. You know, to all, everyone who walks through is getting this, the Dave flattery treatment. And it was a real epiphany moment for me.
我们走进聚会，随着更多人到达门口，你听到他一遍又一遍地进行这种奉承。每一个进来的人，哦，你太美了。这甚至不局限于女性，对吧？对男士，哦，你看起来太帅了。你今晚看起来太棒了。你知道，对所有走进来的每个人都得到了这种戴夫式的奉承待遇。对我来说，这是一个真正的顿悟时刻。
You know, I had known him a long time. I knew that he was sort of smarmy. I had this shtick. And at the same time, I reflected and I realized, you know what though? It really did make me feel a lot better. It made me feel welcome at this party. It made me feel confident as I went into the party with my friend. And the most amazing thing, later that night, the friend that I had walked to the party with,
你知道，我认识他很久了。我知道他有点油嘴滑舌。我有这种套路。与此同时，我反思并意识到，你知道吗？它确实让我感觉好多了。它让我觉得在这个聚会上很受欢迎。它让我和朋友一起进入聚会时感到自信。最神奇的事情是，那天晚上晚些时候，和我一起去聚会的朋友，
I saw her kissing Dave later in the night. And it seemed like his sort of flattery, however insincere it obviously was, had worked its magic on my very smart friend. Yeah. And of course, one of the powerful things about flattery is that the person being flatter doesn't see it as flattery. They see it as, finally, the world is acknowledging what I have long known to be true. Thank you for acknowledging how great I look tonight. That's how it feels. Thank you so
我看到她那天晚上晚些时候在亲吻戴夫。看起来他的那种奉承，尽管显然很不真诚，却对我非常聪明的朋友发挥了魔力。是的。当然，奉承的强大之处之一在于被奉承的人并不认为这是奉承。他们认为，终于，世界承认了我早就知道是真的事情。谢谢你承认我今晚看起来有多棒。感觉就是这样。非常感谢
much for noticing. Yes. Allison Woodbrooks is a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School. She's the author of Talk, The Science of Conversation and The Art of Being Ourselves. Allison, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been so fun. Thank you. Next week on the program, we bring Allison back to discuss a very specific type of conversation. These are the conversations we dread having, the ones we put off, the ones that often end in tears and hurt feelings. If there's a difficult conversation you know you need to have
你注意到了。艾莉森·伍德布鲁克斯是哈佛商学院的行为科学家。她是《谈话：对话的科学与做自己的艺术》一书的作者。艾莉森，非常感谢你今天加入Hidden Brain。这太有趣了。谢谢。下周在节目中，我们请回艾莉森讨论一种非常具体的谈话类型。这些是我们害怕进行的谈话，我们推迟的谈话，那些经常以泪水和受伤的感情结束的谈话。如果你知道你需要和某人进行一次困难的谈话，
with someone, you'll want to listen to this episode first. I poked an invisible Barb into an important part of who he is and he didn't feel seen and acknowledged and valued and worthy of care. Music Do you have follow-up questions for Alison that you'd be willing to share with the HiddenBrain audience? If so, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line conversation.
你会想先听这一集。我把一根无形的刺扎进了他性格中重要的一部分，他没有感到被看见、被认可、被重视和值得关怀。音乐 你有愿意与HiddenBrain听众分享的关于艾莉森的后续问题吗？如果有，请在手机上录制语音备忘录并发送电子邮件至ideas@hiddenbrain.org。再次重复该电子邮件地址是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“conversation”。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirrell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. For more Hidden Brain, be sure to subscribe to our free newsletter. In each issue, we'll bring you more ideas about human behavior, plus a brain teaser and a moment of joy.
Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。欲了解更多Hidden Brain内容，请务必订阅我们的免费时事通讯。在每一期中，我们将为您带来更多关于人类行为的想法，以及一个脑筋急转弯和一个快乐时刻。
You can sign up at news.hiddenbrain.org. That's n-e-w-s dot hiddenbrain dot org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. Music There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在news.hiddenbrain.org注册。那是n-e-w-s点hiddenbrain点org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。音乐 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。